a single beautifully stylized
show-specific studio logo that lasts
under seven seconds
if you want to get the little girl sings
a lament in a foreboding tone cliche
exactly right you really have to nail
that reverb it's clear early that the
cliche department really came to play
today
[Music]
panhandling also underestimating the
market the confusing part of the start
of this show is why there's a drawing
overlaid on the animation as if someone
took a picture and scratched out the
scary face with another scary face on
the scary face but whose memories are
these maybe the show will answer this
later but for that i want to know now is
that an opening in the bridge guard rail
who installs a bridge with an easy
access jump port i like this vander
fella steadfast and full of integrity
i'm really excited to have someone to
root for through the entire run of this
show good thing he's not going anywhere
thinking you can make good content based
on a video game lol i'm not going to
play it but these opening credits are
set to an imagine dragon song who does
this show think we are a random
tracksuit mafia member from the hawkeye
show league of legends huh can't wait to
see the writers incorporate a 131 shove
with a scalar adc in mid while the show
is waiting for baron to spawn let's go
also show takes 64 seconds to opening
title us and now i've got to add that
logo sin back oh well you win some you
lose some but mostly you lose some we're
almost there joe will spend another four
minutes of screen time arriving at the
there where they are actually going nice
getting above it all huh sure is but
tell me again how four of you managed to
scale this wall i get these are scrappy
kids but alex honold would be testing
his grip strength on some of these holds
all right everybody follow me
just don't look down considering all the
jumps and grabs you make are below you
this is terrible advice chubby guy likes
to eat so much he's going to steal these
cupcakes cliche foreshadowing chub steel
cake shadowing also who leaves a plate
of cupcake sitting on the floor of their
open air balcony i don't care if it's an
easter egg this is how you get caitlyn's
i mean ants
once again i know we're in some sort of
alternate universe with magic and sh but
these are just regular children right
i'm going
are you with me or not vai seems to
forget they're balancing on a dangerous
precipice already with her so this
question is asinine and anserine
animals stating scientific facts as if
they are insults we are definitely not
supposed to be here for a bunch of kids
acting casually and loudly kicking in a
door the vibe of their breaking and
entering certainly feels like they're
relaxed enough to be here i think this
is a real valdiani oh
a real valdeoni you say
what about this
that's a nose hair trimmer [ __ ] how
why are there two fully made in
untouched sandwiches here i swear to the
elder drake if the show doesn't solve
this mystery by the end of the episode
i'm adding 20 cents
[Music]
anyone keeping life-altering secret
orbee lights inside an easily open chest
deserves to have them robbed
yep because when you've destroyed a
massive part of the building while
trying to be covert you should look over
the edge of the destruction to be better
spotted by the guards you already knew
were there boy i can't wait to see how
the ragtag group of rebel kids gets back
down from the balcony that was only
approachable by rooftop a moment ago
city alarms that sound like farts also
what good is this flatch alarm anyway is
it supposed to communicate something to
the enforcers are they all just standing
around the city going oh hey the alarm's
going off guess we better
do stuff in some random direction in
this massive city this race through the
streets is really fun to watch and i
find it hard to send because i'm heating
up every camera angle and every turn a
thin vi punches the metal pipe as if
it's a pillow and outpours an enemy
stopping water geyser also considering
she's leading the way here any slowing
effects that move would have had on the
enforcer should also happen to her
friends right
powder slides all the way down the poo
tube and onto a pile of rubble without
the highly sensitive spherical orbs of
arcane chaos booming in her thinly lined
pockets
throwing the guy you had subdued in a
headlock toward the child holding the
treasure bag i think one of the reasons
this show is respected is how much
thought it puts into the references true
fans know that jinx bites her lip like
this and viewers don't but the animation
plays it as if it's a casual detail and
trust us to enjoy it no matter what even
if there are a lot of forced winks the
art and details going into arcane are
absolutely worth the sin off
oh no how will anyone retrieve this when
swimming clearly hasn't been invented
yet
sing commercials huck takes two glasses
and turns to clumsily walk through a
crowd of patrons rather than the more
direct route if for no other reason than
to mark the nerdy person is also
ridiculously clumsy cliche off the bingo
card vaping with actual fire smoke
welcome to the lanes get it the lanes
show is now forcing these references so
hard i'm surprised we don't hear someone
at the bar use the pickup line so are
you a top bot or mid when you say light
of fire they show up with oil which may
be an impressive thing for followers to
do without question except lighting a
fire with oil doesn't work now if the
fire's already going this is a great
thing to bring to help burn your enemies
to the ground not not that i have any
experience with that
cool corkspit bro but you planning on
using all of that because if you're not
you're gonna have to find that cork and
put it back in can no one be practical
with their magismo i think i'm supposed
to believe the powder somehow forgot
that her pocket contained these glowing
orbs of doom i just want to clearly say
that i do not think that would be
possible not only are they clearly the
most amazing things she may ever
discover they were directly beside a
sandwich live closed we don't have a
sign out front and the door is
completely unlocked but you really
should have known there's worse things
than enforcers out there forearm
shadowing if you change your mind
this will reach me
and only me don't worry about verifying
any instruction or the protocol it's a
blue cylinder it's clearly the most
trustworthy of color shape combinations
see that gutter running along the canal
just say yes powder otherwise she's
going to make you put a filthy rusty
pole up to your eye socket with zero
lens for magnification and a whole bunch
of likely pink eye is the only possible
benefit feeding time since the show
wants to show this character as evil
like the fruits of the devil it has him
torture both a rat and a cat to test
this mini moloko murder mixture and
since i want to show how evil i am i'm
giving the show a hundred sins for
making me sit through it but what about
the sandwiches
[Music]
it's a trap
my sister makes these amazing turkey
sandwiches her secret is she puts a an
extra slice of gravy soaked bread in the
middle i call it the moist maker
[Music]
what an incredible smell you
wanna see how that ends by the time this
is over
every one of you is gonna be face down
on the floor
and i'm gonna moonwalk out of here
[Music]
she jinxed his every job
i can't believe you don't care that i
stole only then i got caught i don't
really care you got caught i care that
you got called for stealing something
gets stupid as a [ __ ] tv watch it
does other things too your problem is
never knowing when to shut up look i'm
zippy long stockings when a problem
comes along you might zip it
and when mr bigglesworth gets upset
people die